hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 11 video so really
big things we got to see Morena Baccarin
on the show for the first time and Chris
Heyerdahl who you might remember from
Stargate and a bunch of other
science-fiction guest-starred as another
character from the comic books that I'll
explain when we get to spoilers they did
a really good job of checking in with
all the secondary characters too and
setting the stage for what's gonna drive
the story forward the back half of the
season
we even got teasers for some mystery
shadow figures that we haven't met yet
which i think is a little carryover from
what happened in the mid-season finale
so let's get going okay so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet starting with top five moments
number five it is Shakespeare night at
Arkham so in case you didn't recognize
it or you're not a theatre geek the play
that they were performing was
Shakespeare's The Tempest
the play is a metaphor for all the
characters that they jump around to in
that opening scene if you've never seen
it it's about Prospero this character
who is the rightful Duke of Milan who
plots to restore his daughter Miranda to
her rightful place using illusion and
skillful manipulation it's a story about
Redemption it just involves a lot of
magic it's probably one of Shakespeare's
best plays and I think it was the last
one that he wrote by himself so like
Gordon IV Catwoman even Barbara Kean who
I'm not a big fan of right now they all
are gonna try to restore themselves to
their rightful places everybody just
does not look like they're doing so hot
it's like everybody got kicked in the
nuts after the mid-season finale so just
like Prospero in Shakespeare's play
they're gonna have to call down the
Thunder which is actually a pretty apt
metaphor for the villain number four the
penguin starts to embrace his name
surprise surprise the penguin is not the
biggest villain in this episode I
actually kind of think of him as being
one of the protagonists of the series
he's kind of like an antihero where he
is right now I think you know at a
certain point he crosses the line
becomes full-blown comic book villain
but he's not there yet I had such a
gorilla grodd hallucination when David
Zaius his character was telling him
you're smart monkey but you're a monkey
and I'm the zookeeper so in my dreams
tonight I will see the gorilla nation
led by Gorilla Grodd
you know stampeding through Gotham back
to reality though penguin embracing his
name this is a huge thing for his
character I feel like this was one of
the biggest things in the episode I mean
he had a relatively small part but if
you remember way way back to the first
couple of episodes he hey
the name the penguin it was used to
insult him now he's co-opted it and made
it his own I like the way he said it to
the penguin like the V part was really
important I think the only thing I find
off-putting about him is just how formal
he is it takes a little getting used to
but I am a big fan of Robin Laura Taylor
number three Arkham is a broken-down
maze if you've never seen it here's
actually a floor plan for Arkham Asylum
Arkham has been remodeled over the years
I feel like I mean it's just full of
Easter eggs I've already done a video on
the history of Arkham so I'll add a link
in the description if you want to watch
it in the continuity of the show it's
been closed for ten years and just
reopened I really wanted them to go down
into that basement they did have a cut
to where you see someone getting
operated on that I mean clearly that's
what was happening down there it seems
like it's like this treasure trove of
untouched story where they can go
anytime things get a little slow and yes
I do feel like Arkham is gonna be a
revolving door for villains on the show
now they said it would be eventually but
I mean they didn't really say you know
how often we'd see crazy stuff happen in
Arkham but because our protagonist is
there yeah we're gonna spend a lot of
time at Arkham hopefully seeing a lot
more of Leslie Thompkins Arkham itself
is like this really awesome metaphor for
the psyche Arkham has like three main
levels there's like a first and second
floor and then there's the basement so
you could think of it a lot like the
Freudian psyche you know it ego
super-ego which if anyone's ever taken
like a psychology in film class they
actually they talk about the house and
psycho Norman Bates's mother's house as
being like that - each room you go into
is like either the it'd the ego or the
super-ego you can get really trippy with
your analysis of scenes that happen
inside Arkham so I really hope the show
takes the time to have fun with that
number to meet the electrocutioner in
case you didn't recognize them Chris
Hader doll has done a lot of sci-fi I
mostly remember him from Stargate
Atlantis most recently but he shows up
all over the place he mostly plays
characters like this really sinister
really smart really fearsome I don't
know how many episodes he's gonna be in
but it seems like everything's gonna
blow up in the next episode so they're
probably gonna resolve it then it really
wasn't until the teaser for the next
episode where Edward nygma said
electrocutioner I like that name that it
clicked you know who Chris sader doll
was playing I actually kind of thought
he was gonna be Hugo Strange the name is
kind of what threw me off like they gave
him a different name electrocutioner in
the comic
is named Lester buchinsky there's a
little crossover between his character
and Leslie Thompkins character in the
comics by way of the Stephanie Brown
spoiler character Stephanie Brown helped
capture him eventually and then Leslie
Thompkins eventually helped Stephanie
Brown disappear so the only thing that
would have made this episode more meta
would it be if we had like a Stephanie
Brown character in the episode the show
is making things a little bit simpler
but once we see next week's episode you
know we'll see if they're adapting any
specific comic book storylines in terms
of Arkham it's always been a place where
inmates have been experimented on the
doctors have always been pretty sinister
as you can see from dr. Harleen Quinzel
and my number one moment meet Morena
Baccarin as dr. Leslie Tompkins I
already did a big video on the backstory
for Leslie Thompkins in the comics
Morena Baccarin scare achter obviously
gonna be a slight departure from that it
looks like she's gonna be having a lot
of fun which important and I just could
not be happier about it
I am such a huge fan of Morena Baccarin
I feel like she's gonna help resuscitate
this show I think this episode did a lot
of things to course-correct
I mean it started off really strong but
I feel like the burden is really on the
characters and Morena Baccarin is just
honor a game and I think being the
Leslie Thompkins character is gonna give
her the ability to be a little more
playful so fingers crossed the Jim
Gordon remains somewhat unattached
there'll be a lot of sexual chemistry
between them which I feel like did not
exist in the first half of the season
I'm totally not feeling the Barbara Kean
character but we know ultimately Gordon
is going to marry her which is kind of
unfortunate but that doesn't mean
they're not gonna have fun in the
meantime it also adds some nice depth to
Gordon's character and he's been such a
Boy Scout so far and I think he'll
continue to be so but I think Morena
Baccarin is gonna be a big call to
action for his character like she'll be
a big source of inspiration for Gordon
okay so here's my big question for you
guys which other villains do you want to
see inside Arkham that you think they
have a realistic shot at doing overall I
gave the episode an A - I love the way
it started out I love kind of the scene
they set with this Shakespeare play I
also feel like they were kind of making
fun of themselves - like this is
Shakespeare Gotham is Shakespeare when
you know really it plays out a little
bit of the camp although I think that
they're slowly moving away for that the
only part that really drugged were the
Barbara scenes so if any of you watched
arrow season 2 they had this big
storyline the first half of the season
or really actually most of the season
where a laurel just spiraled out of
control she mostly drank she wasn't
doing drugs like barb
this is Fox they're gonna be a little
bit more hardcore than the CW the Laurel
character while she was spiraling out of
control which is the most unbearable
thing to watch so you just kind of wait
for them to skip over her scenes so I
feel like the same thing is gonna happen
with the Barbra character like she's
gonna be somewhat unbearable to watch
until she turns her life around or
starts to wouldn't it be crazy though if
she's on the same character arc is
Laurel and give her maybe say like a bad
girl persona like that would be crazy
I'm not expecting that like if she
cleans herself up and that's it like
that would just be a waste of time like
what was the point in making her fall
off the wagon
my favorite Barbra scene was when ivy
was pranking her on the phone I was so
hoping she would say my name is poison
ivy whenever she asked she is like the
creepiest little kid ever and I just I
love the looks on her face feeling the
really big Easter egg that I saw that I
haven't mentioned already was Jerry lang
the director of Arkham in the comics
Jeremiah Arkham is the director I felt
like that was an Easter Egg for that
because Bullock walks in and goes Jerry
isn't it I mean it's spelled with a g'
and Jeremiah Arkham is spelled with the
J so it's it's a little bit of a stretch
but I wanted to mention it anyway
hats off though for finally getting us
into Arkham I feel like this is the
place the show needed to get to from the
start
raise your hand if you thought they
should have just started here in episode
1 so in related comic book news tomorrow
agent Carter episodes wanted to it's a
two-hour premiere they're also
premiering the full trailer for ant-man
some of you doing videos for each of
those be sure to watch agent Carter
check out the a man trailer if you can't
watch it on TV don't worry they'll post
that trailer online too be sure to
subscribe to get everything I know
everyone's a little bit worried about
ant-man but I think the movies gonna be
a lot of fun it's just gonna be very
different from other Marvel movies
you've seen so far right now in case you
haven't seen it you can click here to
learn all about Leslie Tompkins
character in the comics like her
character history and you can click here
to start getting ready for agent Carter
tomorrow it's gonna be a lot of fun
thanks so much for watching guys so
everybody high five I will see you
tomorrow
you